hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal waren
und bekommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt und heute machen wir den
englisch trifels way
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob es
eigentlich hätte oder ein geschmäckle es
ist irgendwas dazwischen denn in staffel
sechs episoden neuen macht rachel einen
englisch zweifel aber weil sie ja so
schlecht in der küche ist so gar nicht
kochen kann sind die seiten im
rezeptbuch verklebt und deswegen macht
sie eine hälfte vom english zweifel
englisch englisch und eine andere hälfte
vom shepherd's pie englisch zweifel ist
eine sehr aus england maybe und der
shepherd's pie ist er so ein herzhaftes
ding mit erbsen und bohnen zwiebeln ich
habe mir ein schönes buch ausgedacht den
lese ich jetzt einfach mal vor rachael
möchte für das thanksgiving dinner mit
ihren freunden zweifel machen
obwohl sie in der küche echt nichts
drauf hat zudem kleben auch noch einige
seiten im rezeptbuch zusammen so dass
sie den süßen nachtisch aus früchten und
vanillepudding mit einem herzhaften
shepherd's pie misch das kann nur ein
desaster werden mir ist die variante
ohne fleisch im pudding lieber ja also
wir nehmen das rezept was sie vorgibt
und beenden ist so wie man ein englisch
zweifel beendet und jetzt frage ich mich
ernsthaft muss ich euch noch friends
erklären ich glaube jeder hat diese
serie geschaut und wenn nicht dann
solltet ihr das gegenteil tun ich habe
sie schon fünfmal durchgeschaut und erst
mal auf deutsch aber ich muss sagen dass
mir die englische variante viel besser
gefällt und wenn ihr englisch nicht so
gut versteht dann macht euch die
untertitel an und dann lernt ihr richtig
gut englisch fun factory von bts hat
auch zu englisch gelernt also ich werde
für immer irgendwo noch pts rheins
liegen und daher kommen wäre zu den
zutaten 800 milliliter milch
[Musik]
600 milliliter wale sechs gelbe von die
eier für keine küken töten eine
vanilleschote 70 gramm zucker sind sich
gramm speisestärke eine packung
löffelbiskuits erdbeermarmelade 3
packung himbeere wieder und zwei bis
drei bananen und damit ein englisch
zweifel auch richtig englisch zweifel
mäßig auch sie brauchen wir ein zweifel
glas in cannes soll woanders rein machen
aber da sieht es halt besonders schön
aus
und bevor es mit der zubereitung los
geht möchte ich euch noch kurz mein
outfit präsentieren
es ist natürlich wieder angelegt an die
serie beziehungsweise die folge
beziehungsweise lady trägt nämlich so
ein rotes oberteil und das hatte ich
leider nicht aber ich habe so ein rotes
adidas oberteil die kette trägt sie auch
und weil die serie glaube ich definitiv
90er 2000er habe ich jetzt noch so eine
kette ich weiß nicht ob sie da getragen
haben aber irgendwie hat sich das gut
angefühlt und jetzt beginnen wir mit der
zubereitung
wir brauchen 800 milliliter milch und
geben sie in unseren top ten venues
inside your bis zu klein
secure topfes zu klein
die poetin den nav ad hoc dass tobi
vorankommt
einpacken sahne sahne und nun bringen
wir die sahne zum erhitzen nicht kochen
lassen nur erhitzen und während unsere
milch so richtig warm wird müssen wir
unsere eigelbe trennen und denkt dran
das eiweiß könnt ihr aufbewahren denn
euer freund macht gerade sehr viel sport
und freut sich über sehr viel weiß was
er zu einem reim machen kann
[Musik]
ein trend ist eigentlich super easy
klasse einfach bank
das eiweiß kommt in den kühlschrank das
bekommt unser sportlicher freut
und wenn ihr keinen sportlichen freund
habt seid selber sportlicher freund zu
dem eigelb kommt zucker und wir müssen
unsere vanilleschote auskratzen das ist
die königsdisziplin tools so hat ob ich
wüsste man hier mache hier seht ihr das
goldene schwarze kommt dann 370 gramm
von unserer speisestärke muss dazu und
das muss jetzt miteinander verrührt
werden gerade auf dass ich noch gar
nicht gesagt habe das wird ein
vanillepudding richtig gut und du willst
wenn ihr mal richtig das gefühl haben
wollt zu kochen machten vanillepudding
selber ihr fühlt euch wie der könig ich
bin stolz drauf
oh mein gott ich entdecke live ich
entdecke gerade vor wieder das kaufen
und somit war das heißt wir müssen jetzt
schnell agieren wir nehmen es ein
bisschen milch und ging es in unsere
pudding mischung einrühren das runter
und dann geben wir diese milch pudding
mischung zurück in den topf klingt
einfach die kunst ist nur dass man das
so schnell höher
es ist eigentlich zu stoppen anfängt so
eine chance darstellen
unsere mädels jetzt heißt da kommt
das ist unser pudding ich habe irgendwie
das gefühl zu viel mitgenommen zu haben
aber das kann eigentlich gar nicht nicht
sagen theoretisch noch 200 übrig
ich habe 50 milliliter zu viel milch
genommen weil ich falsch ab gemessen
habe deswegen versuche ich das jetzt
noch mal ein bisschen auf dem topf zu
erhitzen
nun stellen wir uns wieder derbys freuen
wie schmeckt vanillepudding wasser
flüssig ist ja okay so war wo mein gott
ein bisschen erhitzen hat geholfen es
ist jetzt polen geworden
wir geben jetzt unseren pudding in die
andere schüssel und natürlich müssen
unser gesicht zaubern nehmen und hier
haben wir unseren handgemachten
selbstgemachten supergeil vanillepudding
wisst ihr was an diesem pudding so gut
ist ich hab zwar 70 gramm zucker
reingemacht aber für die masse ist das
eigentlich relativ wenig und er schmeckt
so war nämlich poddig aber nicht so süß
an den meiner ist noch lange drin und
eigelb und so dass es auf jeden fall
nicht gesund aber lecker der pudding mit
jetzt erstmal schön abkühlen am besten
nach draußen stellen wenn es draußen
kalt ist dann ist sehr praktisch und
bevor es weitergeht räume ich jetzt
einmal so richtig schön die küche auf
cashback
ich muss einfach zu einer anderen zeit
drehen dieses oder ich sollte da mal
eine gardine machen wie die sonne
richtigen weg blockt aber jetzt kümmern
wir uns erst mal um unseren englisch
zweifel der pudding kühl draußen noch ab
ich habe ein deckel draufgemacht damit
das nicht so eine haut bekommt aber wir
können ja schon mal mit den ersten
schritten beginnen das glas mit einer
schicht löffelbiskuits ausfüllen
natürlich wollt ihr das ganz schön
machen und legt ihr so schön aus das
sieht doch gar nicht mal so schlecht aus
hier welt sein halbieren wir unseren
level diskret und wir stellen diese
löffelbiskuits am rand entlang kaufen
das machen jetzt einmal rundherum
[Musik]
nur der hielt ein bisschen klein geraten
ich habe dieses ding jetzt nicht hoch
dass ich nicht marmelade dran gemacht
als zweite schicht nehmen wir unsere
schöne erdbeer konfitüre digital vault
heute eigentlich eine mit weniger zucker
nehmen weil es schon genug zucker da
drin aber die bauma schmeckt einfach
super lecker ich versuche mal erst mal
mit dem pinsel jetzt die marmelade zu
greifen dass so ein bisschen zu
verschmieren und dann müssen wir noch am
rand das dekorieren unsere pinsel
technik ist nicht so gut wir nehmen
einen löffel und dieser schritt kann ein
bisschen dauern
[Musik]
so nach einigem rumgebastelt sie ist
eigentlich ganz gut aus für mich ich
glaube was wirklich besser ist wenn man
diese samt marmelade nimmt ohne
stückchen weil das sind doch jetzt eine
ziemliche fummelarbeit war und das
ergebnis nicht so schön ist wie mit der
samt marmelade also samt marmelade ich
bin blöd aber es sieht gut aus und es
wird auf jeden fall schmecken und jetzt
brauchen wir unseren pudding mit dem
deckel bekommt dass sich diese komische
auch noch einmal gut durchrühren und
zwei drittel von diesen pudding müssen
jetzt als schicht braucht natürlich
müssen wir noch einmal probieren
[Musik]
und nun brauchen wir unser himbeeren die
himbeeren zuerst kommen unsere himbeeren
in ein sieb sind viele himbeeren dann
fantastisch ich habe acht himbeeren zur
seite gestellt und den rest packen wir
jetzt in unsere zweifel party sieht aber
auch schon geil aus irgendwie ne auf die
himbeeren kommt jetzt noch eine schicht
löffelbiskuits das passt voll gut so ich
mache da jetzt mal pudding drauf und
dann noch eine schicht vanille pudding
drauf kommen das sieht eigentlich ganz
hübsch aus kann schon sagen als nächste
schicht kommen unsere bananen dran wie
sollten geld sein und reifen länger und
die müssen wir jetzt schneiden und auf
den streife legen und am rand so eine
kleine deko dingens machen
[Musik]
bananen jetzt isst eine banane party
mein gott ich glaube das schmeckt ich
möchte stellt euch mal vor
himbeeren bananen pudding löffelbiskuits
das kann nur lecker sein so schön aus
angeber das sehr
und nun kommen wir zu unserem letzten
schritt endlich die sahne schön 400
milliliter sahne obendrauf knallen aber
vorher solltet ihr noch eure küche
freuen auch gründe küche in 3 21
ich schreibe jetzt kurz auf und dann
zieht das tut gleich weg und dann sieht
es doch dass du ganz schnell gegangen
wäre der trick wird auch einfach nicht
alt oder wie geht's schnell des drauf
ihr besonders heiß draußen wir brauchen
jetzt die restlichen zwei sahne becher
und geben sie in eine rührschüssel
nummer 2 und die muss jetzt
aufgeschlagen werden
wir sehen uns gleich wieder um seine ist
jetzt steif und das susanne kommt jetzt
in diesen sprit konnten
der rest kommt einfach hier über das ist
unsere erste schicht sahne und jetzt
kommt's spritzbeutel und die kamera gibt
auf den letzten metern
unser ok und keine bugs drauf und jetzt
noch zur dekoration
[Musik]
er ist so schön da mag man jetzt gar
nicht so rein dürfen und das
kaputtmachen von nun leute stellen wir
uns wieder der wichtigsten trage wie
schmeckt der english zweifel oder der
gerettete eine streife aus friends ich
will das gar nicht essen
das sieht so schön aus und ein tipp der
steht auch im buch also so für ein paar
stunden kühlschrank stehen lassen dann
schmeckt er natürlich am besten weil
dann alle geschmäcker schon durch
gesucht sind aber weil ich sofort
probieren möchte meist es sich also ich
erst jetzt im buch das ist rot die samt
mama das besser aber seht ihr was ich
meine
also ich glaube am besten man geht jetzt
einfach mit so einem löffel da rein und
rot sich was raus ich mach mir mal hat
in die schüssel geld hat sie jetzt nicht
so schön mehr aus aber ich fahre gleich
ins büro und wäre das auf jeden fall an
die leute dort verteilen und ich bin
sehr gespannt was sie dazu sagen
sieht auf jeden fall sehr gut aus aber
jetzt kommt es noch im kühlschrank und
jetzt stellen wir uns wirklich der frage
wie es schmeckt also ich meine sieht
jetzt sehr häufig aus kann man schon
zugeben guten appetit
halt deinen mund oh mein gott
und diese frischen himbeeren also wir
müssen jetzt die frage beantworten wie
schmeckt es schmeckt es schmeckt muffig
sah nicht dann schmeckt man noch die rpr
marmelade von der ich echt mehr hätte
rein machen können diese löffelbiskuits
sind jetzt so leicht aufgeweicht und
schmecken absolut geil
also ein bisschen wie so ein tiramisu
mit pudding von die bananen und himbeer
die geschmäcker passen einfach alles so
gut zueinander das ist irgendwie so ein
schicht salat nur mit obst und sahne und
pudding timo wirth zu einmal probieren
das ib bereit ist es so lecker es ist so
lecker und probieren wollen wir doch so
fröhlich noch ist die ja genau und der
pudding ist auch nicht so süß und der
produkte deutlich zur süße passt zum
mega geil zusammen er leute ich kann
euch den englisch schreiben absolut
empfehlen wenn ihr zum beispiel gäste
empfangen gold ist das ein perfektes
bisher zum vormachen das ist nicht so
schwerwiegend kuchen das heißt man kann
es nach so einem abendessen auch noch
essen wollte sieht cool aus also wenn
man es dann da so hinstellt ich glaube
es dürfte noch ein bisschen kälter sein
also der pudding und so das hat alles
jetzt bei mir zimmertemperatur aber wenn
man zwei drei stunden köcheln gelassen
hat oder zwei ein bisschen kälter aber
ja ich habe ich schon sowas aufgegessen
ihr seht es schmeckt verdammt gut
die folge gefallen und wenn ja wie ein
schluck erstmal runter zeigt es mir mit
einem daumen nach oben und abonniert
meinen kanal hättest du nicht gemacht
habt dann könnt ihr teil dieses sports
werden
dieser spot hat noch keinen namen aber
er ist hier
und falls sie das rezept ganz in ruhe
mal ausprobieren wollt dann findet ihr
es in meinem kochbuch in der video
beschreibung führt euch die erste link
zu der amazon seite wo es verkauft wird
könnte es über den link bestellen weil
dann krieg ich sogar noch von dem link
ein bisschen anders ab und dann kriege
ich richtig viel für dieses buch also
nicht so viel aber immer noch also mehr
sie können aber auch bei thalia kaufen
gehen oder in einem
anderen buchladen eures vertrauens oder
online shop macht es wie ihr wollt
hauptsache ihr holt euch das und sehen
uns dann beim nächsten mal wieder chips
krieg kostet ich habe ja eine lieb und
vergesst nicht auch mal ab und zu sport
zu machen und nicht manuell zu essen bei